- Hi, everyone.
Sal Khan here from Khan Academy,
and I'm excited to talk a
little bit about safe browsing.
Our guest today is Kelly Hope Harrington,
who's a Senior Staff
Software Engineer at Google.
Kelly, welcome.
- Thank you.
Happy to be here.
- So safe browsing,
my sense of browser, we,
you go to some websites,
it sends up some webpages.
What's the worst that can happen?
- Oh, well there, there's all sorts
of bad things that can
happen on the internet,
and I think some of the ones
that are come to mind first are things
like phishing or social engineering.
So someone is trying to trick you
into thinking they're someone you trust.
So you share either your
personal information
like your password or your
credit card information,
or maybe you do something
that you wouldn't otherwise do
because you trust them.
And that could be something
like downloading, installing malware.
So, malware is something that
will take over your computer.
The attacker is trying to
do something to get value
out of you.
So, maybe they want to take some
of your personal data and
sell it on the dark web.
Maybe they want to do
ransomware where they lock
down your computer and
won't let you use it
until you pay them money.
Or maybe they wanna do something sneakier
and do crypto mining in the background
so your computer gets hot
and slow while that's happening.
We also see unwanted software.
So, unwanted software might
have something that you do value
but also does something else.
- Yeah, so I just wanna
make sure I understand this
'cause we talk in other
videos about phishing where
someone pretends to send
you an emergency letter
from a bank or whatever,
and many of those phishing
attacks usually try to get you
to some type of a website.
And this is where, once
again, you're browsing now.
You need to make sure that
that's actually the website
that you think it is.
- Yeah, yeah.
You know, I think that the attackers
know you're looking for stuff,
so they're trying to take advantage
of you're already naturally trying to go
and download something,
and that is their opportunity
to try and trick you,
and try and get you to do something
that you weren't otherwise gonna do.
- Super helpful.